this badger is about to meet its fate
but these people have come not to kill
but to vaccinate it this is a critical
edge or buffer zone in Derbyshire and
this is one of hundreds of badgers in
the county to have been given the jab in
the hope of halting the spread
throughout england of bovine
tuberculosis campaigners say it's by far
the most important weapon in the fight
against this disease actually we're
calling on the government to roll out a
national vaccination programme we've
shown in Derbyshire that at scale we can
operate a vaccination program we have
hundreds of volunteers working with us
we're cost-effective this is the way
forward we don't believe you should be
shooting buggies we believe you can
vaccinate them and in Derbyshire we're
showing the way
not only does wildlife artist Lynn hazel
Smith sculpt badgers
she's also a trained volunteer
vaccinator it's a privilege and a
privilege to be in that position not
many people see badges they often see
them by the roadside dead but to see a
live badger know that you've worked that
hard and that you're going to vaccinate
this budget and you're going to save it
from a chance of contracting TB as well
and to be there with the actual creature
is an utter privilege
the relentless spread of bovine TB is
hit cheshire farmer Phil Latham hard
there is a passion to look after the
animals but there's also the just that
you have your outgoings you've got all
your bills to pay and for no fault of
your own all of a sudden your business
is cut out from underneath you it's very
challenging nationally more than 33
thousand cows were slaughtered last year
because of bovine TB up from almost
twenty seven and a half thousand in 2014
although Badgers are a protected species
more than 19 thousand were cold in 2017
up from ten thousand eight hundred and
eighty six in the previous year
according to the wildlife trust a
further 42,000 could be added this year
are these 100 volunteers in Derbyshire
wasting their time I think they're
making themselves feel good about
themselves I don't think there will be
stopping the disease spreading there's
no paper in the world that shows that
vaccinating Badgers reduces the
prevalence of TB in cuddle the
forthcoming government review will
undoubtedly influence how many more
animals both cows and Badgers will die
in the years to come for now this is one
of the lucky ones Mike McCarthy Sky News